I think we're going to see a narrative and some evidence that these GLP-1 drugs that reduce your cravings,
the people on these drugs are actually consuming less social media.
There is a cohort of people that are on social media 24 by 7.
And whether it's porn, whether it's Instagram, whether it's TikTok or Twitter,
it is an addiction and that is it gets in the way of the rest of your life.
And I think we're going to find that people on these drugs reduce their social media consumption, among other addictions.
And I wonder how the market is going to react to that.
So I think that's coming. I think we're going to start to see news.
In addition to reducing your nail biting, your alcohol consumption, your consumption of Pringles,
you're also less likely to be on Instagram 14 hours a day.